dernière tête d'oursins de la journée
sont en train de cuire des six heures
joue elle a pris la mer mais la pêche
n'a pas été miraculeuse très peu
doussain contiennent des oeufs et les
conditions météorologiques n'étaient pas
idéales
c'était très dur donc qui fait qu'on y
avait beaucoup de courant la main
n'était pas l'eau n'était pas cléo cléo
et qui fait que que fan des portes et
que au lieu de ramasser tous on était
obligé de faire plein dans les venues
pour pouvoir l'amour pour éviter ce type
de fermeture prématurée il faudrait
selon les professionnels
changer la période la balade toutes les
attentes
ballard à la guerre et pourtant avant
l'ouverture de la campagne
des tests sont réalisés pour vérifier la
qualité des eaux sans on fait toujours
des tests 20 à 30 jours avant on fait
une belle prospection tout autour des
citoyens d au sein la qualité des
correct mais seulement on n'avait pas
prévu cette fois plus mais tri la pluie
à chaud la qualité de l'os nicolas le
bianic et le tout nouveau directeur de
la mer nommé le 19 octobre
et pour lui le dossier des ours est très
important les prochaines dates de pêche
lie 16 et 17 décembre sont pour le
moment maintenu
effectivement la décision et de
maintenir ces jours nous verrons avec le
comité régional et en fonction des
prospections qui vont être faites
si l'état de la ressource permet ou non
de
poursuivre la pêche sans ces deux
journées les marins pêcheurs doivent
prendre leur mal en patience
rien n'est donc encore perdu la saison
dix jours ça peut encore se jouer
si la ressource est acceptable